good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
change management fundamentals with your
host Oulu sukoon my name is Richard and
after the century will be mostly in the
background helping Oulu so that
everything goes smoothly change
management fundamentals change
management it is all about finding the
right tools and training what kind of
certification will help you in a career
as a business will help you for
transitioning individuals teams and
organizations finding the right methods
intended to redirect resources business
processes budget allocations modes of
operation basically reshaping a company
or an organization Wow
I'm excited to see where Oulu takes us
today with this if you do not if you're
not familiar with olu olu is a
professional project manager and emmalin
to implementation consultant with vast
experience over 30 years and both the
public and private sectors and provides
training as a coach and a mentor to a
range of clients
Olu has worked with the oil and gas
industry in Nigeria and then in the UK
with a number of different companies
hsbc BS KYB Fujitsu services the
National Health Service the skills
improvement Network / exil international
CRO my delicious keeps going his
academic work at Oxford in universities
data and system analysis program among
others attest to his continuous quest
for knowledge and personal improvement
Lulu is a master in project management
for those who are not familiar with this
form of webinar let me go ahead and
introduce you to your dashboard and find
your question module if you can go ahead
and just say hello in the question
module I see we already have a couple
questions coming in go ahead and say hi
this just lets us know that the volume
is working and texts on there there we
go hello I see a lot of emails Rula
great to have you here Lu Darb great
thank you for being here
Ondra Helen we have a lot of people
coming in this is exciting so yeah go
ahead and use this question module
throughout the session and at the end
we'll have a 15-minute question and
answer given the sizes crowd will
probably go a little bit over on that
and that's okay and we'll try to get to
as many questions as we can on here
we already have a couple questions the
slides themselves will not be available
for download but you can request a copy
of the session and I'll remind you at
the end on that we get to the QA so
hello everybody great to have everybody
on board if you hear something awesome
and brilliant interesting insightful and
you want to share this in your social
channels whatever your social channels
are Facebook Linkedin tweet you can use
the hashtag SL webinars that way people
can find it and you'll make them jealous
wish you were they were here you didn't
come here to listen to me I'm proud to
introduce
Oulu it'll be your host for change
management fundamentals go ahead sit
back relax have a cup of coffee tea or
if there's evening where you were at
maybe a glass of wine and enjoy thank
you and happy learning hello Olu and
welcome to simply learn today let me go
ahead and unmute Oh Lou help you there
although I'm sure here Oh excellent
excellent welcome to simply learn today
we're very excited to have you
fantastic thank you very much Richard
right it's all I say the ball rolling
and obviously today we'll be discussing
the fundamentals of change management
and Richard thank you for that glowing
introduction sometimes I actually think
you were trying to introduce a professor
of change but trust me this is exactly
who I am and I believe you can see my
screen so you could extend a dovetail
between project management and change
management and obviously implementing
solutions across different sectors and
today my focus
is actually for us to look at what
actually is change management but beyond
that we're going to consider the concept
of change management and look look at
that visa phase project management and
see that in connect interconnectivity
between change management and project
management we equally would take a sniff
short our change management model in
look at project failure reasoning why do
projects fail why do they succeed and
I'm sure from our discussion today
obviously there will be some things that
will resonate with some of you and some
new things that we can pick up as we go
on as we go on obviously we'll look at
how do we integrate change and within
the project management environment the
focus will be to look at the big to big
players as relates to project management
methodologies so we're going to be
considering how change affects you know
your work of project managing within a
prince2 environment and how change
affects your operations within the PMP
side of things also we will possibly
look at some career opportunities in
change management and in project
management and I willed as usual you
know call you to action because that's
the essence of spending this love lovely
woman are together in a nutshell you
would agree with me that most project
managers follow established project
management methodologies in order to
achieve success and like I've said you
might be amazed you know meeting and you
know your experience your your expertise
might be using one method or the other
over the years you would really come to
terms that some degree of failure is
evident in most projects worldwide the
the morado of you know the fact that we
lose traction on time on cost and
quality on risk you know is ever-growing
within any project management
environment
but one important reason for this
failure is a fact that projects of an
implement change and in its turn change
can introduce new risk you know to the
project itself in fact I'm sure that you
will appreciate that one of the
characteristics of project is the fact
that it's actually set up to to
implement a change and successfully
change successful change can be
influenced by variety of factors which
can affect the result of change itself
as well as the objectives of the project
so change management in context looks
looks at a strategic view and a
structured approach to transition in
whether they are individuals or whether
they're team so we did you know the
organization as a whole from a current
state to a desired future state and many
times when we talk about change
implementation you hear people talk
about the as ease or the you know the
current state we are and of course they
are trying to mirror that with A to B or
the future state where we're going to be
so change and project management must be
considered as an integrated transitional
activities you know between them and so
the success of one likely depends on the
success of all of the other because the
work you know hobby and in hand you
cannot operate a project without
implementing change and of course your
implementation of change will actually
be more successful when you look at that
in context of doing that within the
project project environment I tried a
little bit to just look at what some
notable players globally I've said about
change and I value very much well John F
Kennedy said you know saying the change
is the law of life and those who look at
look only to the past or present are
certain to miss the future so in essence
all we're saying is that the concept of
change it's something that's going to
bring about you know a change you know a
move from where we are
- certainly where we want to be and
there are benefits or there are you know
perceived outcomes you know to that to
that change
on its own itself so you will see a very
good perspective if you look at this
lovely picture in here is the fact that
obviously they some desire they some
inspiration by that singular golden fish
went in to meet the other pals
you know having a good swim on their
reports and this this what change is all
about it's all about moving from one
state to the other he's all about moving
from one position to another
let's consider some generic definitions
of change management and I'm sure some
of these you know you would agree with
and in some instances some of them you
would want to query yourself there's a
school of thought that change management
is a systematic approach to dealing with
change but from the perspective of an
organization and we could be on an
individual level but it's somewhat
ambiguous term change management has at
least three different aspects and these
aspects were so whenever we talk about
change management or managing change
we're looking at the concept of adapting
to change we consider how do we control
change and of course how do we affect
you know or put into reality
they change itself
I love these other bid you know the one
that says that change money meaning can
be defined as a set of processes that is
employed to ensure that significant
changes are implemented in an orderly
controlled and systematic fashion to
affect organization change so one of the
goals of change management is that is
with regards to the human aspects of
overcoming resistance to the change in
order for members you know to buy in to
change and to achieve the organization's
go often with an orderly and effective
transformation
there is no gainsaying that
something that is so evident even with
all human beings including myself is
that we really don't want to change you
know it's it's it's a tall order for us
to to even think of of the change itself
and nature you know time and again tends
to even forces to to imbibe you know or
to adapt to change or to control the
change or to affect change you know as
we go on so project my project change
management itself the production
management aspect encompasses all of the
processes necessary to determine where
you are either as an individual or as an
organization and that got passed
actually to where we want to be or where
we've planned that we're going to be and
the activities required to actually get
back on track if those are not aligned
so essentially if you look at what we're
saying is that we consider you know
we're actually are we at this point in
time and of course we're looking at
where we planned to be so that that's
obviously looking at where we are is
taking measurements you know some key
performance indicators looking at some
measurements or matrices on where we are
but of course looking in the future to
actually see where we plan to be and
that is you know in Eric doing in
essence doing some level of firm of
evaluation but of course as you know
you're never going to have you know a
smooth sailing a smooth running you know
changing implementation in fact that is
why it's called change because then
there's so much you know risk or level
of uncertainty that is attached to that
change so how can we get on track again
in the event that what we planned you
know to actually or where we plan to get
to we're not there at any point in time
and and this whole circle you know tends
to bring into into traction some element
of you know projects change management
and it's also where actually are we now
you know kind of measurements into that
and looking at where we plan to be doing
an evaluation of that and of course how
can we get back on track again
in the event that want to implement some
correction or corrective strategies
there different types of change and I'm
sure depending on where you look at it
or this depend on the spectrum in which
are looking at it from the two major
categories would obviously be the
individual change management which
revolves around you know the person but
of course you also have the other strand
which is the organization change
management so how it affects the way the
organization does their thing you know
carries out operations and of course
looking essentially to how we can
transit from where we are to actually
where we want to be and I love this one
here because then it tells us you know
we're looking at the processes the
currents where we do things and of
course that transcends to how we really
want to be the to be processes as we
move from the current state which is a
ASUS processes and looking at how you
know we want to do things in the future
the old essence is looking at how we can
reduce cost how we can improve quality
so you know within change management we
tend to talk about quality improvement
process improvement strategies however
the transition period of change which
may lead to adaptation is not only a
time-consuming one but also a risky
process I mean this like I said before
there is so much you know level of
uncertainty either as it relates to
individual change management or as it
relates to organization change
management but within the as this
process really what we are trying to do
is we're trying to define the process
we're trying to put measures in place
and of course carry out some level of
analysis as we position ourselves in
such a way that we're trying to reduce a
cost and improve the quality yeah then
of course we'll look at improvement
strategies and of course how we're
managing the change process itself
essentially what we're trying to do is
get ourselves you know to that level
where you know we can control or how be
it we can sustain you know the change
that has been implemented so a movement
from the current where we work or the
current way with
things or the currents we operate to the
future way we want to operate or want to
move things going forward but how be
looking at how we can reduce the cost
and improve it improve the quality or
you know either operationally or
individually is essential to to change
management I love this one because
recall what I said that change is
something that is inevitable in life but
again when you look at the emotional
cycle of change then of course you tend
to appreciate the fact that if you put
it on a graph like this I love the way
we we get started with it because
anytime you're trying to implement a
change I have within it you know it's
something that any individual is - it no
it's something that an organization is
is buying into we tend to want to begin
with that level of on inform optimism
because at that level you know you just
see everybody's like okay well bring it
on
as we go on within the change circle
then of course there is that because
remember we've started with that
uninformed optimism then of course when
we get to the level of informed
pessimism that is where obviously people
are now get into the nitty-gritty of
that change that has been implemented in
an organization you can see that we dip
into that level you know and this is at
a level where we start you know
appreciating over time the hopeful
reality of that change implementation do
lessons is that we're trying to actually
move so a successful change strategy
will be warmer in which we're trying to
move people from that level of
uninformed optimism to that of a
rewarding completion you know where
we've gained that inform optimism and
people are all you know all in the know
of what has been delivered and people
are able to appreciate the benefits of
where we are actually going but again
remember change has that element of high
risk and of course it also has that
element of time that we need to build
into it to actually allow for the change
process to be to come to fruition so the
purpose of project management
remember when we'll bring any project
into existence there are essentially
four things that we're trying to do
within the project environment as a with
in project management we're carrying out
activities relating to planning we're
doing some a great deal of delegating
because within the project management
environment nobody does it all so apart
from the planning exercise we did we get
into the delegating you know aspect and
of course as we move on we carry on some
elements of monitoring you know the
activities or the tasks that have been
run ultimately because we want to ensure
that we're able to control so really
those four strands come very useful
within every phase head of project
management you know work that we're
doing again remember project management
is all about implementing a change so as
we move from position a to position B we
will be carrying out some elements of
planning we'll as long as you know as we
go on the process overtime will between
some level of delegation we're between
some elements of monitoring you know
throughout the project and essentially
ensuring that we can put some control
measures along the line so a big
question to ask yourself that is so why
is project management ways for the chain
management important well when I give
the introduction I I did say that
projects seldom run exactly according to
plan we have we've planned it but of
course we know that because of the great
level of uncertainty for which projects
you know are prone to we might slip on
those plans so protect deliverables must
be maintained by carefully and
continuously managing changes so the act
of you know change management comes into
play particularly as relates to what we
want to deliver and of course these
deliverables where are their products or
their outputs for those projects for the
project at hand either by rejecting
those changes or by approving those
changes so those approve changes are you
know if they are proof changes then of
course they incorporated into a revised
baseline so if you take an example for
where we've agreed that we're going to
obviously go into construction of
of of for house and we've agreed that
the color for the painting of the
interior is gonna be say cream color if
however the painter or the team manager
that we is carrying on the painting
exercise goes out there and cannot find
the defined or the agreed color for
which we're going to use then of course
a change request comes into play where
we need to consider that and this is
where you know that level of either
accepting or rejecting that change comes
into play so if it's approved then of
course we we have a revised baseline and
of course we can you know and if it is
rejected
dito it could be rejected or approved
and the basis of you know how does this
affect the time of the delivery how is
it going to impact on the cost what is
gonna be the impact of these change
requests on the quality of what
one-to-one to deliver how will these is
this going to introduce risk that is
beyond what we can cope with our
obviously is this change going to have
affect the scope of what's one to
deliver and essentially looking at how
this is gonna affect also the benefits
because remember all of our projects is
ensuring that we can do a cost-benefit
analysis and so this is quite an
integral part of project change
management and that shows the importance
of it because throughout the life of the
project we want to make sure we're
keeping an eye on days and making sure
that nothing just slips in no slips out
you know particularly as in as regards
what we've agreed on in the baseline
okay so project change management is
important because it also ensures that a
project team and the stakeholders alike
have an accurate understanding of what
has been completed in the project to
date and what should be delivered in
total so that element of looking at what
are we doing where are we now and of
course looking at where actually are we
go into so is that is a transition of
where we are now and of course what has
been planned when I started I said we're
gonna look at the two big players within
the project management environment or
two big players within the project
management
methodologies I'm sure there are people
on base call who possibly at one point
to the order or currently they use
prints to as a way of managing projects
if you look at the project management
team structure within the fringe to
environment so these these area here
because recall the cooperator program
management is not part of the project
management team so your high the highest
level of your project management team is
your project board which actually is a
constituent of your senior user you
executive and senior suppliers and of
course down here is exactly what we're
talking about a change authority so all
change requests you know come on to the
change authority they will be able to
consider the change that's been
requested and of course look at how that
affects the time the cost the quality
the risk the scope and the benefit to
see whether that's going to be agreed
you know approved or that's going to be
rejected and maybe the other thing to
mention is that any change that is
approved within the prince2 environments
it's actually funded by the change
budgets and this is this is an amount
that's quite you know set aside for
change related activities so it's quite
different from the entire project
budgets with prince2 and change it gives
us so when you look at the area of
control in a stage because that is that
is essentially where the philosophy the
principle on philosophy which says it's
not actually to prevent change actually
if philosophy is that we need to imbibe
change we need to be proactive enough to
identify the change and so that is why
you can see that within the control in a
stage process within the prince2
methodology you know all change requests
are captured they examine so we capture
and examine the issues and the risk and
of course we review the state state
status ultimately we will want to you
know take corrective actions and of
course escalate those issues at risk and
of course equally as a project manager
will you know write highlighter
so on a day to day basis the project
manager is responsible for managing
change within the controller in a staged
process one of the key activities of the
controlling estate process is to capture
an unexamined issues and risk
so as these issues come in again
remember that for those who use prints
to that there are three types of issues
there we've got the request for change
we've got the off specification and of
course we've got a problem or concern
within prints to the problem of concern
is anything that can be handled with a
project manager informally and so that
come in lo can be recorded in the daily
log which is more like a diary of the of
the project manager but if it's a
request for change or a no specification
these are things that need to be
formally attended to because then they
could actually revolve or change the
baseline so this forms the entry point
for the managing change and change is
considered as as a type of issue
like I said in prince2 so that's why you
see people say you know within the
project team they say no we're we've got
a CIO that is a change of ways that has
come in is going to be examined it's
going to be evaluated and of course if
it's approved then of course we can
implement that change now let's look at
the other big player PMI the project
management institute and again I'm
Valerie fact that you would have people
in here who are members of the PMI by
virtue of being PMP profes certified so
if you have that and of course if you
even go straight to your PMP mi page you
can see this caption there because he
says change is inevitable and
accelerating organizations can't that
manage it effectively we pull ahead of
their competition change initiatives are
time-consuming and costly but by
approaching change management with a
disciplined approach organizations can
survive and thrive and this is you know
they this is more like the Gospel
according to PMI you know the project
management institute because it's
looking at how change management can
actually you know help organization
development but of course it's gonna be
done in a disciplined and controlled
manner
you won't know about a pimple guide the
project management body of knowledge
this is a body of knowledge that is
produced by the project management
institute these body of knowledge is
actually revised and reprinted every
four years currently we're working on
the sixth edition and I think this this
is this is almost done and dusted now
and hopefully by the first quarter of
next year I mean we should be having you
know this this and so it is in play you
know for PMPs so the sum of knowledge
within the profession of project
management and it is used to document
and standardize general accepted project
management information and practices by
these I'm in the pimple guide okay
currently where I know that I said this
year early
Eon you know we're all using a fifth
edition and the sister edition is in a
public domain you know and of course
ready just a little comparison with what
we have with a fifth and a sixth edition
you know for those who want to look at
it you can see in the fifth edition we
consider performing Quality Assurance as
against managing quality in the fifth
edition we're actually looking at
controlling race but now it's been
changed to monitor and risk and of
course you know controlling so all the
aspects related to control tend to have
changed into monitoring now in the sixth
edition because again we're looking at
them pipe in some elements of agile you
know into the project management you
know platform right so with the four to
sub processes mapped into five processes
steps must mapped into five processes
with NEPA chief caught in issue
serious pretty scope forget cost or the
budget for the shadow or project quality
now other change requests cover needed
preventive or corrective actions to
forestall negative impacts later in the
project so again this is just you know
trying to retrain what we were doing in
the in the prints to protect the
environment where we said you know it's
been classified without a request for
change or is an off specification and of
course it needs to be analyzed it needs
to be captured if we need to fund it
then of course we're using a change
budgets you know to carry that activity
out right just let me grab one cup just
a sip of water okay and again with a
pinball guide and its elements of change
so you can see the change control where
we're identifying with documenting we're
approving all we're rejecting and
controlling changes to the project
baseline it's a game it's all about
baselines and I tend to say this because
to a great extent you know we we tend to
always want to look at it what's the
difference if I am implementing change
in a prince to environment how does that
differ to when i'm implementing change
you know within the PMP or the PMI the
pinball guide well again as you can see
the change control process where are you
using the prince2 methodology you using
a PMP or that a pimple guide again it
all begins with us you know identifying
the change and this is where CRS change
the quest you know templates and change
request forms are usual and of course
ensuring that we can document those they
documented you know requests can get
into that change Authority where we
either approve or we reject such changes
so then a PM within a pinball guide
we've got a change Control Board which
is formally constituted group of
stakeholders responsible for
viewing evaluating approving delaying or
rejecting changes to approach it with
all decisions and recommendations being
recorded so this just gives us an
indication of and people call it
different things you have the change
Control Board you have the change
control authority you know just name it
it I think it's Joe it's all a function
of how the organization wants to call it
but of course as input you say the
project for for us to consider the
change we're looking at the project
management plan will consider the
shadowing forecast we're looking at the
cost for forecast
you know validated changes and of course
there are tools that we use using your
expert judgment we could run meetings
you can use analytical techniques you
know in in the pinball guy and the
output of course for us is to look at
you know how does that affect our work
performance reports how do we update our
project management plans for the
documents updates you know to actually
incorporate whether this change has been
accepted or rejected and how we're going
to deal with it again just quickly back
again to just reiterate remember I was
talking about request for change and/or
specification and problem of concern of
course this is the request for changes a
proposal for a change to a baseline
including baseline improved product
product descriptions you know and for
the project manager what the project
manager is doing is capturing that
carried out impact analysis proposing
actions free and of course presenting
that to the person or the group who has
the competence to accept or refuse or
reject the request for change and like I
said in most instances you would have a
change of turret a board or a change
authority in place you know to
reconsider that and that may be the
constituent of representative from the
user environment from the supplier
environment and from the business
environment and the project board again
would ultimately approve reject they
would defer this decision or request
more information or ask for exception
plan if however you know going forward
they see that yeah that's something that
they want to do if is a enough
specification and of course that's
that's where there's some identified
errors omissions project is or will not
be delivered as described in the product
description so for example you want a
car you know you working on a project to
produce a car and of course you've
realized that no we're not going to be
able to meet to the time or we we see in
that well um how be it as against using
a particular color you know for painting
the dream of the of the car certain or
the different colors been used then of
course the project board can look into
our grant any concession to that owing
or in other ways it could instructs that
the or specification be resolved you
know and it could be for the decision or
equally ask for an exception plan I just
took this because then this will give
you a quick snapshot of what a p.m.
knowledge areas and the process groups
are like you know particularly if you
look in towards the PMP side of things
so as it relates to protect management
integration project scope management you
know what do we do with project time
management how does that affect project
cost and you can see the monitoring the
controlling process you know that
actually go into it so for example in
the cost management tax rate of things
that's where we actually carrying out
cost control you know initiatives to
ensure that at least we're not
overspending on the pro on the on the on
the project right and and again you can
see in here you know some of the process
and the IMP use so take again the cost
control aspect that I did mention before
this is concerned with determining the
current status of costs influencing
factors that will create the changes and
determining if it has been changed
managing actual changes changes such
life such as the cost baseline the
project funding requirements the
performance reports
you know what performance information a
proof change request and of course
project management plan and you know
like I said quite a number of tools that
the pinball guide you know encourages
that we use cost control system
performance measurement analysis we can
also do some forecasting perform project
performance reviews project we can use
project management software and of
course there is some element of very
variance management that can come into
play and ultimately the output of this
is because we want to be able to get
cost estimate updates cause baseline
updates forecast save complete
completion so anything if you know the
end date is going to be changing then of
course that needs to be reflected as we
go on we said that market needs are
constantly changing so market adaptation
strategic business planning and the
flexibility at which we work the speed
the cultural changes their modern
mandatory things you know that we need
to actually ensure successful change
management or successful management
implementation and so most of the common
project management methodologies like I
did mention before such as critical
change forget management the ccpm the
prince2 the PMI essentially focus on
three strands you know and and B these
are essential they did they look at the
scope they look at the cost and they
look at at a time because they a full
complement of scope cost and time has a
very great deal of effect on the quality
of the product within the project itself
so those project management
methodologies do not take into serious
consideration things like the business
cultural issues or change management and
adaptation but even as we speak you know
that there is that human element that
comes in today's and so to a great
extent we imbibe in that as we go on
there is the pro ski ad car model this
is a model for change so we're talking
about modeling change these are
goal-oriented change management model to
guide individual organization change
this was actually created by pro skier
under which is Jeff hate and AD car is
an acronym that represents the five
outcomes an individual must achieve for
change to be successful these five
outcomes details so the Erica you're
talking about awareness so there's a
some element of understanding the need
for change understand the nature of the
change there is a D which you know talks
about it desires so you've got support
for change you want to involve and
engage other people so and of course
there's a knowledge which is where
planning comes into play and of course
we're asking ourselves how we're going
to implement it the ability comes into
because that's where we need to make a
great deal of of that because you can
see the how comes in here but of course
want to actually go ahead and implement
the change so beyond just having the
knowledge there's got to be the ability
to implement the change and acquire
necessary skills and resources and there
is a reinforcement which is to sustain
the change and revise the success
factors just as we speak for those who
might be interested in the ad car model
if you choose to I can just quickly help
where sway I thought this one was on
just build me one quick second
trying to actually take you into the
right okay
if you if you get into the website for
that there is there's obviously the
opportunity to download an e-book to
that effect and of course have a look at
it so like I said we change management
there's a triple constraint and this
triple constraint constraints relates to
scope the cost and the time so these
constraints are things that we need to
consider when we're trying to implement
change management particularly within
the project environment if you look at
these three constraints you see how it
affects the project plan because then
within that you're looking at time
management plan the scope management
plan the quality management plan each
amendment plan respond and plan and
ultimately it has to affect your change
management plan and of course with with
the change management plan what we carry
out that tends to bother on the triple
constraints of costs scope and time we
look at the processes that is helping us
to know who is doing what are we doing
when are we doing what we're doing and
how actually we're doing it it also
helps us to look on consider the tools
we're going to be using in some
organizations the use of Excel you know
spreadsheet would be a factor you know
even to managing change we can have some
standard templates that will be quite
useful and again a lot of project
management software that would help with
change management procedures and I would
even let you let you into some of them
as we go on the activities in there's
gotta be you know integrated activities
and of course we're reviewing when am i
analyzing and approving change requests
like I said they change the change
request is captured it is considered and
reviewed analyzed and of course it's
either approved or rejected and we
monitor the baseline so there is that
element and within a project management
plan itself you know going on from what
I said before
you would have quite a number of plans
and you know if you're in project
management you would have had of you
know you doing some requirements
management plan of scope management for
you know doing a shadow plan your course
management plan you know process
improvement plan so so many of them you
know but of course ultimately what we're
trying to achieve is you know how will
this plans obviously these plans would
have been baselines so we're looking at
you know our cost base line scope
baseline and if anything is gonna change
if change management process is the one
that's gonna dictate or describe how
changes are monitored our changes are
controlled and how they're incorporated
within the project management plan so
how do we incorporate change you know
along you know each of these areas and
of course we select the process that
once you so we describe which project
management process you know want to use
to actually you know manage the change
itself within the project environment so
when you look at the change process from
what I said before it's a question you
know the change and of course a change
request is captured we review the change
and of course if it is approved Oh fine
then of course would inform and of
course we continue me however there is a
need you could also have an instance
where there is a need to adjust a plan
and of course we can execute a new plan
we're updating our records or documents
and of course you know so we can carry
on that process you know is an actually
I creative process within life of the
project itself as a whole right again
the monument tools at our disposal you
remember when we studied I didn't
mention moving I mean change management
we're talking about you know moving from
the as ease that is the current state
because our desire is actually to move
to move to the future state which is the
to be process and so people time and
again they've carry down you know and
you can use your flow chatting or you
know use Mike's of Max of Visio you know
to to dictate what processes you know in
place looking at your decision points
you could equally use techniques like
force field analysis you know to look at
the present or the desired state and of
course you know do your matrix
collection because then all these have a
great deal of effort or we deal of work
if you want to explore some Avenue with
change management software okay you
might find some of these quite useful
Splunk there is IBM rational clearcase
in fact this is the current one I'm
currently going use it on the project
I'm working on
and of course you've got fusion 360
you've got the BMC remedy the emitters
version is version 9 it goes
freshservice you got intellects I mean
the you know so many software out there
that will help you you know to actually
carry on and manage the change process
I'm sure if you're into project
management oh well the project
management software you know all out
there from your Clarizen to your p6 by
Oracle to your Microsoft Project to your
easy projects your liquid planets your
recall modeling what front I mean the
list is just endless you know but you
can see the integration between change
and project as you explore each of these
because again remember from what we said
the all essence of you one of the
qualities of project management or one
of the qualities of of project one of
the catalysts of project is actually
implementing change so the change
management model like I said you will
also consider the culture of Moodle for
project success but of course within the
organization
you know itself we're looking at what
processes what values are in place so
the project management competences the
processes the design the performance you
know indicators all you know coming to
play you know for us to actually have
success within the organization
framework itself Jim Cutler you know
wrote days way we was talking about
eight reasons why project fill oh sorry
why change fill so and you could you
could see them you know highlighted not
establishing a great enough sense of
urgency not creating a powerful enough
collation
like in a vision so every change
requires vision
under communication division by a factor
of 10 not removing obstacles to the new
vision not systematically planning for
and creating short-term wins declaring
victory too soon because then you might
just think you're there but of course
you know there might just be some other
things that need to be done you know I
love a saying I mean that same with a
smile that the central issue is not
strategy it's not structure is no
culture is no systems the core of the
matter is always about changing the
behavior of the people so even within
the project environment is about
changing the orientation that's why I
said in here you know in agreement with
what John Carter said you need that
vision to be shared and of course making
sure that everybody is running with our
vision okay how do we sustain change you
mobilize the energy and commitment
through joint identification of business
problems and their solutions okay it's a
joint effort then you develop a shared
vision of how to organize and manage
come competiveness
you identify leadership because change
will not go forward without you know a
leader a leader in place so you need
that level of leadership you can be an
individual leader I can be a team leader
but of course that level of leadership
needs to be we need to focus focus on
results not on activities else we just
can make plain you know around so many
activities and which are not yielding
results so the focus for change to
sustain change has to be on the results
and of course we start to change at the
very very then let it spread to other
units without pushing it from the top so
it's like I said from the from the top
is going to be all involving you monitor
and adjust strategies and responds to
problems in a change process so for
project managers to be effective there
must be competent change managers there
is no two way about it you cannot be an
effective project manager without you
know exhibiting a great deal of
competency within prudent change
management because like we said project
management can have strategic value when
there is a link between the level of
effectiveness and how affect efficient
a project is accomplished and when the
project's outcomes can provide overall
business value this is what changes all
about so change management itself is you
know as a strategic and structured
approach needs to transition that
element of you know that holistic
approach to product and services how
does how outcomes you know within a
project you know come into play again
remember it's all about looking at how
we move from our current state to our
future state where project management
you can look at it you know tends to
focus so much on the technical side of
the project change management you know
tend to look at the people side of the
project so project management and change
management may seem as separate but they
are intake you know integrated in
practice because for us to move from the
current stage to the future state what
we're you know essentially looking at
how will the technical manage to the
people because you needed people to
actually you know use the technicalities
you know at your disposal so they this
is why you know for that transition
state to be a successful one we need
that marriage between technicality and
the people we may be a symbiosis between
projects and change again just to remind
you of those triple constraints of time
of costs and of quality again sorry of
scope remember we talked about you know
the project time refers to any part of
the project schedule including the
duration of the individual tasks the
milestones and the deadlines you want to
look at the costs and the cost to relate
or the budget relates to any part of the
projects materials or suppliers or even
external contracts if you are thinking
of some level of certification then of
course this might come handy because
then you might be looking at the
satisfied chain management professionals
cause the practitioners have identified
many benefits again in ccmp credential
professes knowledge and experience of
pairs and markets with the letter C cmp
added to their name the exam itself it's
150 multiple-choice questions and there
are no trick questions in it and there
are four options for each question so
you normally get your ABCD
down the line again so I've told about
the CCMP you can also see the APM G has
a program for change management the BCS
they British from to society also has
especially certificate in project
management so these are areas that
obviously can explore again days a
graded of project chain management in in
also in IT and of course within this
education guide for simple and we've got
different courses and of course you can
see how you know a bit of you know mix
and match will get us onto the project
management expert master's program your
choice
according to protect druker successful
carriers are not planned that they
develop when people are prepared for
opportunities because they know their
strengths their mettle of work and their
values knowing where one belongs can
transform an ordinary person hardworking
and competent but otherwise mediocre
into an outstanding performer and I
think this is where we want to be so
it's complementing the experience that
we have with a qualification again
looking at the change control process I
remember we need to maintain a log where
we receive the change and of course that
change is you know goes through a
process of analysis and will rate in if
we're going to accept it or if we're
going to reject it within the project
and that moves on things remember most
project managers follow established
project management methodologies in
order to achieve success some degrees of
failure is evident so and this is why
successful change can be influenced by
variety of factors which can affect the
result of change itself so change
management is the strategy and structure
at which a transition in individuals the
teams and organizations from our current
state to a desired future State workwise
out there there are change analyzed the
change managers the change facilitators
transformation managers implementation
consultants process improvement analysis
service improvement and you know
specialists I mean an e-coat across
different sectors whether the bank
seto manufacturing the health sector
construction real aviation you know for
me it's just a call to action change is
a process it's not an event it's not a
one-stop event so the call to action is
just looking and how well are we going
to transition from where we are really
to where we want to be and you know
using all these you know borrowing a
lead from the fact that even as we work
within projects it's making sure that
we're delivering on time on cost within
budget you know and of course within
their grid scope making sure that those
key performances for project success is
you know I've had you know time cost
quality the risk is remark you know
manage we're working within scope and we
can achieve the benefits for the project
well this is where I would like to hold
a halt and leave the floor open Richard
I mean even though we've got questions
that we want to do it thank you
excellent Lou and thank you as always
I'm always learning new stuff and
wishing a was doing less in the back end
and more paying attention so I could
pick up new information wonderful
session as you know simply learned is
the one who sponsors these sessions and
it's not a small thing they actually
have to put together a team in the back
and so at this point I always take over
the screen because we're on launch a
real simple poll while we do the
question and answer so don't worry we're
going to get to the question answers and
release if I said that name right you're
welcome
I always like seeing thank-yous on the
questionnaire so I'm going to take over
the screen right now with a poll and
then while that screens up one of the
questions that comes in that I take care
of is are these slides available is a
session available the slides are under
copyright so no we don't make the slides
available to everybody so you can't
download the copy of all the slides we
have but you can go in too if you go to
simply learn calm and go under support
you can request a copy of this session
and they'll send you a link can take up
to 12 hours or 24 hours because they
go and double-check it but then they'll
send you a link to the session you can
go back over it and watch it again and
you know fast-forward the stuff you
already know and get to the stuff you
wanted want to see again let me go ahead
we got some great questions coming in in
addition to that we have people from all
over by the way this is exciting we got
from here in the US Florida Calgary in
Canada India all over the place in India
Delhi New Delhi I think we even have
someone from looks like Taiwan
France excellent so we just popped in
there they're from France Bangalore so
we have Bangalore in India so we have a
little bit of everything the UK
throughout the UK
excellent so let me go ahead and for
Oulu can you go a little bit on what's
the big difference in change management
between prince2 and PMP what's the
difference between prince2 and PMP maybe
even more general question fantastic
right when we obviously when we got
started I mentioned to you the two big
players which were Prince tieu and a PMP
side of things now they let's talk about
the similarities force even before the
differences now the great similarity is
the fact that with these two project
management methodologies change needs to
be controlled so within I don't know if
Richard is right screen still visible
now we have the poll up so the polls are
a-okay right when I did mention
previously I did show a slide relating
to the project management team the
project management team structure within
a prince to environment and one of the
elements that I didn't mention was the
change authority and I said that within
approach within Prince to environment
you know people will call it different
things they will call it exchange
authority board or the change authority
you know but the point is that is a
designated role within Prince to that
considers all change request the
come into the project and that is an
integral part of you know managing
projects according to Prince - now the
element that comes into it remember what
we said is that a change within Prince
to environment we did mention that there
three strands or three ways we consider
change one it could come in as in quest
for change
- it could come in as an off
specification and three could be a
problem a concern and it was the problem
of concern that I have said that could
actually be made you know handled by the
project manager informally the request
for change or the or specification will
be handled formally and in being handed
formally I mean you know it's neat gold
either truly change the authority board
and of course ultimate approval by the
project board the funding for that
change is something that needs to be you
know taking charge of by the chamber yet
that is quite separate from the project
budget going down the PMP side of things
I also did mention that with the when it
comes to the PMP we have the change
Control Board which is a formally
constituted group of stakeholders
responsible for reviewing evaluating and
approving delaying or rejecting changes
to a project within all decisions and
recommendations have been recorded so
again it's making sure that that
structure is in place so whether we're
talking of you know the prince2
environment or whether we you know
working with the PMP environment change
has to be controlled and measured
approved or rejected excellent in just
following up on this since it's along
the same lines
does it add value to get both
certificates fantastic - two
certificates you know as it where you
know have different focuses the prince2
certificate is Jed because it emanated
from the UK environment is Jade more
towards the UK the you know Commonwealth
countries the United Nations area it's
more focused on processes principles and
themes
unlike the PMP which like I did mention
food off you know when we started I did
say that the project management body of
knowledge is a some knowledge in the
profession and of course it's used to
document the standards you know and it's
it's run by the PMI so there are two
different areas or two different focuses
so it depended on how globally or how
you know effectively you want actually
play your game as a project manager you
know the options are there either to you
know get certified in one area or
combine the two of them you know and of
course the sky is not the limit and the
good thing is a simpler land offers
those certification options excellent
and that we miss had a couple people who
missed the first question on the QA yes
you can go to simply learn comm to get a
copy of the session and they'll send you
a link it does take up to 12 to 24 hours
and the slides they are under copyright
so no we don't supply the slides
directly you know it's just the way the
nature of the business that they have to
do that and we had like three or four
people who missed that part and it's not
actually YouTube I think it's um an
Amazon video recording I forget what it
is but it's a free recording so you can
get a copy of this session we're going
to simply learn and we have a more
specific question down here and I'm I'll
go ahead and close the poll here and
just after this next question why most
mergers and acquisitions M&A fail so is
it like there is a culture difference or
are there other differences that's a
question a very interesting one failure
success of I mean any change
implementation will be you know to agree
to extend determined by you know how I
love I love if you look at what we're
talking about when we when we mentioned
projects failure reasoning you know and
I did refer to John Kotter the six-way
gave eight reasons why change fail and
did mention that to a great extent with
all Papa's and intend if we don't
establish a great enough sense of honour
urgency in what we're doing or we're not
creating a powerful enough collation or
when you know all they change actually
lacks vision or we're under communicated
now because that's that's an integral
part of success to any change how much
of communication are we given now you
can have over communication or just like
an avenue communication or you know how
well are we removing the obstacles for
the new vision involving the people you
know it's a critical aspect you know and
of course every change is gonna
ultimately be down to the leadership so
you know leader shaping change so you
want to talk about measures and
accusation how strong is a leadership
for that change because that's gonna be
a determining factor now when I say you
know strong it is not talking about the
individual it could be it could be led
by a team you know is how was a team
dynamics to actually make sure that we
can monitor we can adjust the strategies
in response to problems in the change
rules process excellent excellent
it sounds like my family life but let me
go ahead and close the poll that way if
you have any slides you want to show
you'll have control again of the screen
ways to sustain change just comes up to
the last poll we said we have a lot of
questions in here and trying to pull
them through because some of these are
answered during this session I know we
have a couple people we had high Oulu
sugeun this is Sanket from hyper better
know if cenk it's in one of your classes
certainly we get that to where people
come in there they might be taking one
class I want to see what something else
is about so they come to our webinars
exciting I know we had a couple other
people who are already looking at
classes and I guess I don't if they're
looking for different instructors or
just seeing what the different options
are so they can get a little more detail
and we you know it's kind of hard to
cover all the differences between
prince2 and PMP
we're still getting questions in on that
specific this one is specifically in the
IT industry the difference between
weapons - and PMP in the IP industry and
ITIL I guess plays a big part in that
also yeah I will say on it well again if
we underscore this whether we use in
prince2
or we're going down the route of PMP I
always come from the school of thought
that those for instance of project
management is what we need to be
focusing on project management is all
about planning delegating monitoring and
controlling now whether you choose to
now go down the route of use in prince2
as a way of planning delegating you know
monitoring and controlling or whether
you choose to use the PMP you know the
body of knowledge you know - - actually
the pin book guide as in body of
knowledge it's all gonna be down to what
kind of project you're running of course
we know that you know prints - we work
with almost all sides of projects but of
course they say a great level of
documentation that goes into it you know
from the business case you know to the
state gates you know to the end stage
upholstery highlight reports and all the
other things for the PMP side of things
we know the focus is more on optimizing
you know you operate and structure you
know and doing all your calculations
which you don't have in prince2 so it's
it's it's doing if you like it's it's
making sure we get into the end but of
course you know choosing the way to get
there I say to people the OL essence of
you wanting to get to a place and using
your car is to move from point A to
point B now whether you use a Honda or
use a Volvo I think is going to be
determined on how you they drive on one
together
I think mine's more like a Honda all
beat up right now so this is here's a
question I'm gonna go throw in there
although we could probably do its own
classroom session how do you deal with
resisting change and deal with the
pessimism that people bring in their
people resisting change maybe some of
the examples for your own thing because
that obviously covers like a huge amount
of information there that you could give
on that I bet now thank you Richard
now again that level of change it's
gonna come into play over the success of
any change implementation again remember
what we started with if people if you
can get a buy-in from the people now
there's going to be resistance I mean
that is obvious you remember that lovely
picture I showed you about you know that
graph and I'm gonna try and go back to
that one this this this will help
because yeah this lovely one okay when
we got started okay and I give you an
example I need to work on a project
within the National Health Service here
in the UK and when we started you know
people were like okay yes yes and down
the line when you know you now start
having issues where people are saying oh
you mean I now have to learn how to use
a laptop or you mean I now have to learn
how to you know use mobile devices
okay now that level of informed
pessimism is actually coming you know
stepping into the into their shoes
but all the time what really do want to
do the moment we start pushing you know
across those benefits you know that
outweigh the costs you know it's more of
a plus and a minus situation for every
change implementation can we get a
situation where people were getting
buy-in from the people who are
pessimistic about it moving them as to
see the benefits as the city success
stories we're not saying that there are
no defects we're not saying that you
know everything is gonna work honky-dory
remember change has a great element of
didn't see a risk attached to it but as
much as we're able to give the people
the level of confidence and you know the
supports that they need then of course
we're good
you know to actually get them to buy
into the change either as individuals or
as an organization excellent
sounds like my family life how do you
get them to buy in now we had some
questions can you please share some more
details specific to ccmp and the of
course we have the master's program it's
simply learned and how that fits
together make sure a little bit more
specific just to the CCMP and how those
all fit together sorry I lost unless you
there so the question is can you please
share some more details around the CCMP
specific and the and specific to simply
learn what is available from simply
learn I see you've already pulling it up
that's great oh okay
just to quickly you know mention on that
the ccmp which is the certified change
management professional program is one
that is a licensed international
standard related to the work of change
management so really it's it's an
independent body you know if you like
but of course you provide certification
with a credible regrows developed
program so you've got that level of
credibility you know that goes around
with it and like I did mention you know
you've got the it's it's assessed in
such a way that you go into a global
register you know where you can like I
said you know credit yourself with a
ccmp name you know that a professional
in these fields but beyond that also
remember I did mention that you've got
other programs within change management
you've got a PMG international change
management program you've got a BCS
especially certificate in change
management program as relates to simple
land itself the programs we run you know
where you have programs in ITIL or your
programs in prince2
your programs in MSP the project
management expert masters program as you
can see you know you've got your four
strand which has to do with a project
management work and of course you can
see how that moves from course one to
cost you to cost three to cost four so
it's a blend or a combination of you
know two or more of these you know for
us to get you to that master's level
program either using some element of
lint certification to complement what
we're doing or we're using some element
of ITIL to complement what we're doing
and whether we use in Lynn or ITIL you
know change is also part of but a puzzle
of it excellent and it's good you have
the slide up here because one of the
other questions that came in is how is
change management differently different
or similar in the agile software world
and I guess he right there is agile
scrum master exactl bit how that fits in
there
oh I mean as you know the OL essence of
implementing using the agile framework
is because we have something to deliver
and the beauty about you know using
agile is the fact that you know the
goalpost is it's not like a fixed goal
pool you know post for which you know we
work in we're working a dynamic
environment where we're saying you know
things can and that is where this chrome
on a daily basis you know we're looking
at what have we done where are we you
know what are the obstacles or
impediments you know that would not
allow that move forward
so is that dynamism that comes into
these as again the traditional waterfall
approach you know to project management
or to product delivery so the agile you
know from master program is a viable
option you know for imbibing and you
know encouraging change I'd as an
individual or within a corporate setting
excellent
and we are almost 15 minutes over so I
do have to close it because there are
other webinars to go on and
unfortunately we can get one all day
which would be fun for me and we still
have there's still a number of questions
we weren't able to get to for those
people who weren't able to get to
questions we do have it community simply
learn calm or if you go to simply learn
calm and go into the community that is
an open forum and a lot of experts go in
there and check those community forums
there's also if you're in the classes
specifically there's also simply talked
down there for those who are members
that simply learn that have even more
information specific to the courses but
you can difficult in there and ask
questions if you write when you get to
simply learn calm a little chat window
pops up so you can ask questions
concerning the simply learn courses
right there and I apologize those people
weren't able to get to because we do
have some more great questions that came
in but again we have to go ahead and
close the session and you do have those
two different areas different resources
you can go to you know sure share the
webinars with other people simply learn
is growing it some I was just reading
all the numbers on them that the pool of
teachers is now just off the charts so
we have a lot of expert help like Oulu
you leave these different classes and
whatever you're trying to go in your
career and use the forum to it's a great
way to explore and ask some questions
and definitely come to some more
webinars because these webinars are a
great way to learn more in depth before
you go take the class and just make sure
hey is this what I need Olu thank you
for being here and thank everybody else
for being here we had a wonderful crowd
today I just love it I wish we had all
day I'm gonna go ahead and close the
session now if you have any last things
to say go ahead and do that now no no
I'm good
all right I think everybody were taking
their time out of the day to join us and
listen to me in the background and Oulu
and his expertise look forward to seeing
you in the classes and wish everybody
happy learning and a good journey in
your career in your professions thank
you very much
you